on Monday a mob of college town commies
in North Carolina toppled a 93 year old
Confederate soldier statue at the Durham
County Courthouse and proceeded to kick
the hunk of metal while shouting
obscenities we'll analyse Plus Amanda
Presta Giacomo Jacob Arry and Paul Bois
joined the panel of deplorable zhh to
discuss the Trump train smashing CNN
kumbaya nonsense and the bubonic plague
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
so we're going to get to this the
toppling of the statues but first there
is a little bit of business to cover I
just got some bad news this morning my
father called me he texted me first he
said call me you get a chance I called
and we found out that we are distant
relatives of Hillary Clinton I'm
somewhat tickled by it we already know
that I am a cousin of Beyonce we haven't
proved it yet but I think it's obvious
but we are I have a first cousin
once-removed I think who married a
Rodham which makes me and Hillary
cousins so Madam Secretary whenever you
get the opportunity would love to have
you on the show and have a little family
reunion now we have to move to smashing
smashing statues so the left this has
been brewing for a long time the left
has wanted to topple these Old
Confederate statues any remnant of
antebellum South they want to get rid of
and luckily we were you know I guess
because people have smartphones now
they're always recording these things as
they happen we have video footage of the
social justice warriors toppling the
statue last night in Durham can we play
it you know actually Marshall I think
that was that it wasn't the college kids
last night that was the Taliban
destroying a 1500 year old statue of
Buddha and yeah the way you can tell is
the accent on the Allahu Akbar is it's
not a southern accent I was more in
Afghanistan accent do we have the actual
clip that we can play
[Applause]
they are just charming aren't they just
screaming like hyenas the little animals
maybe you see that one got a kind of
doughy guy at the end flipping it off
and yelling obscenities so the issue
here is did you if you didn't hear what
they were chanting they chanted no cops
no KKK no fascist USA later they chanted
we are the revolution now I can get on
board I guess with no KKK or no fascists
or no Nazis were the first one is no
cops which they may have just been
describing the event in Charlottesville
on Saturday then that might have been a
recap of how little the police did to
stop the violence there but I think what
they're they're obviously far-left
radicals and we do know that the people
who came and pulled down this statue
were members of the IWW the Democratic
socialists of America the workers world
party far lie mean actual communist
right these how did they pull it down
Michael so they put a title noose around
its neck and ripped it down and there is
it's pretty funny that they chose this
one because it wasn't a statue of Robert
Elia it wasn't a statue of Jefferson
Davis it was just a Confederate statue a
generic statue dedicated to the boys who
wore the grey and it was built a century
goes built a hundred years ago and this
there a lot of cities are following suit
five cities around the country after the
events in Charlottesville have said
they're going to pull down all their
Confederate monuments officials in
Kentucky Maryland same thing at the time
has come after decades we have to pull
these things down and so are the Donald
a wonderful source for news I check it
every day it's the the reddit page for
Donald Trump supporters they pulled out
a few other examples of monuments that
obviously now we have to take down for
instance the Taj Mahal quote rupes built
by hindu slaves time to tear it down i
don't know how it's been allowed to stay
up for so long the bill clinton of
course we quote can not glorify rapists
tear down this symbol i couldn't
possibly agree more then FDR we have to
remove this one quote internment camps
for Asians stole their property also
communists all true and finally did you
know that Martin Luther King Martin
Luther King the Great
social justice activists he was against
gay marriage got to pull that down and
in the filter and way come on now no no
I would film don't get off topic Martin
Luther King was against gay marriage so
obviously we got to pull that one down
now I have no sentimental feelings for
the Confederacy
i George Cobb Knowles and ancestor of
mine was killed as a Yankee at Boyton
plank road I'm a Yankee through and
through but I really really don't like
this move to take down two Confederates
statues and statues of any kind for that
matter so why not take down the
monuments all of the argument it seems
is on one side that we have to take them
down but why not there are at least 1500
Confederate monuments around this
country so I guess this little gang of
roving communist is going to have to go
to each and every one of them all around
the country and there is a lie that's
going around the internet that these
Confederate monuments they're really a
lot of them were built in the 60s as a
response to civil rights it's not really
about southern culture at all that isn't
true the vast vast majority of these
monuments were built before 1925 they
were built as the nation was finally
healing from its Civil War so that you
know for the first time you had
Confederate soldiers who are receiving
federal benefits for being American
veterans
you had that generation sort of dying
off and and even rich Lowry from
National Review which was formerly the
definitive conservative publication he
says it's time to take them down he
wrote quote the monument should go some
of them simply should be trashed others
transmitted to museums battlefields and
cemeteries and rich Lao I couldn't I
couldn't disagree more but rich Lowry is
invoking robert e lee himself in this he
he points out that Robert Lee Ely noted
quote I think it's wiser not to keep
open the source of war but to follow the
examples of donate those nations who
endeavoured to obliterate the marks of
civil strife and to commit to oblivion
the feelings it engendered now I don't
know if rich is aware of this but robert
e lee was wrong about a number of things
particularly with regard to the civil
war in particular the civil war he was
completely wrong about the civil war why
wouldn't we defer to him
how to recover from the Civil War I'm
not so sure one of the responses that
they very often make the social justice
warriors who want to take down statues
are that you know we took down not see
statues after World War two when the
Allen 1946 the Allies ordered the
destruction of Nazi monuments and Nazi
statues I think this is a stretch I
think it's a stretch to compare World
War two and the way that we treated our
enemies with the way that we as a nation
decided to heal from our Civil War to
deal with our original sin of slavery an
issue that we've been trying to grapple
with since the Constitutional Convention
since the Declaration of Independence
you know President Lincoln summed up how
we were going to treat this out he said
with malice toward none with charity for
all we reunited as a country we've
treated those soldiers as veterans we
treated those rebels as our fellow
countrymen another little point to
notice as the Nazi regime lasted for 12
years the south is a political and
cultural entity blasted but by the time
of the civil war it had already lasted
for 250 years and it's lasted 150 years
since then as well now if both people on
the left and the right are getting this
issue wrong the mayor of Richmond who's
had plenty of calls to remove monuments
from Monument Avenue there the mayor of
Richmond levar Stoney sums it up pretty
well we have to ask the truth the future
by using these tunnels not for
celebration but as tools to educate I
will see violence and never civility or
whether we like it or not they are a
part of our history
that's it and removal will never wash
away that same they hate that Milton
will not go away just because of tear
gas doesn't start normal of engine comes
from statutes on a tree line
three it resides in hearts model and the
way to change part is the educator ah
thank you thank you mayor stony for
being the only voice of reason it seems
in this debate he he went on to say a
president was in another place quote at
the end of the day those statues are
offensive to me very offensive to me I
imagine they would be they're offensive
to me too since I killed a rant
great-great-grandpappy Knowles but you
know what I'm going to focus my time on
destroying vestiges of Jim Crow where
they live in our city public education
you name it so he makes this great point
toppling these statues will do
absolutely nothing for the people who
are living other than obscure their own
understanding of history their own
understanding of their communities but
it won't have any tangible benefits to
improve the lives of these people which
he could do you could all focus his
attention as the mayor on actually
improving the lives of his constituents
this same thing has been happening at my
dear alma mater Yale it's been going on
for years they wanted to rename the
residential college it's sort of like a
dorm there from john c calhoun because
calhoun was a proponent of slavery
so calhoun college has been the center
of this debate for years they finally
decided they weren't going to rename it
then they decided they were going to
rename it because that administration
these days has absolutely no backbone
but last year it got even worse a yale
employee took it upon himself to use a
broom handle to smash an old stained
glass piece because John Calhoun was on
it he he destroyed this property this
piece of art and not only did Yale force
this guy to lose his job and not only
did they not press charges they rehired
and they gave him his job back they
didn't press any charges and and then
they suggested that they form a
committee to decide which other pieces
of art should go into hiding because
they weren't politically correct or they
refer to some aspect of our history that
we don't like to acknowledge anymore
that's not fashionable to acknowledge
absolutely pathetic is evidence that not
only at Yale is a microcosm of this but
now around the country the inmates are
running the asylum and I can think of no
better example of the inmates running
the asylum than bringing on our panel of
deplorable --zz we have them in studio
today we have all three in studio first
of course first and best Amanda presto
Giacomo and then we're also joined by
Paul Bois and Jakob Mira this is an
all-day Lee Weyer panel today so let's
just go really quickly down the line
we'll start with Paul what do you think
of this should we take down the
monuments should we not take down the
monuments I think it should be left up
to the municipalities and the people of
the town I think mission agra honest
healthy discussion not somebody at
Huffington Post writes an article and
then you get a bunch of SJW down that to
tear down the statues let's have the
discussion if the statue should stay up
true absolutely not no way this is this
is step one I mean they're going to keep
coming what else is next what I'm going
to take down next why were you racing
our history it's important to remember
this stuff remember the races remember
when we overcame and how we did overcome
that and we United and came back from
slavery so absolutely 100% no don't give
them an inch she'll take a mile we're
taking them down on their own stop them
Jacob I think I'm the only southerner
actually on this panel thank God but I
liked it but I actually I agree with
Paul I think it should be left up to the
local municipalities as a person of the
south
I've seen how how hurtful kind of the
lost cause which is such a ridiculous
thing to talk about the civil war in
that perspective and in New Orleans
there is actually a statue that was
dedicated to racism we were like we're
it was a statute we're proud that that
we're proud of our white heritage that
one deserved to be taken down yes
obviously I would I would have given
money for the bulldozer to knock it down
but as far as the historical statues I
think I don't think we should pretend
the Civil War didn't happen we need to
remember that it was a hard time and we
killed from it and should be left up to
the locals whether they want to take
them down or not so Amanda you seem to
have the strongest opinion on this and I
tend to agree with you what do you think
about this argument they say well we
won't destroy them we'll just put them
in museums we'll put them in cemeteries
put them out of the public square yeah I
think again that's that's kind of
erasing
our history I mean that that's better
than this nonsense where they're
toppling them themselves that's
disgusting
but but again I mean I think it just
show I mean and it's a slippery slope to
as always so well so we're taking down
next right are we going to go you know
in colleges they're already going after
you know they're like just not covering
people because they were slaveholders
there looked burning books in colleges
right now Rockford wanted to get rid of
Cecil Rhodes out of yeah for college
right right so we see this everywhere
and I think it's just really dangerous
to set this precedent we'll redo this I
mean yeah local news penalties sure but
where does it stop why do we set this
precedent I think it's a bad move to do
it there might be some good intention
but it could lead to some really bad
things for just you know censoring
history absolutely Roger Kimball wrote a
great piece when all the nonsense was
happening at Yale I suppose that is in a
particular time it's been going on three
years now yeah but he wrote a piece
about how we need to rename Yale itself
because obviously Elihu Yale was a slave
trader and he was a British imperialist
and it's unthinkable
good name George Washington Hedda
Stanton you know she wasn't even for
getting married I love Nexen well that's
very center mystery you know we need you
Washington wasn't in favor of gaming is
outraged let's start the petition now it
you raise a great point which is that
the it seems that we're a little less
educated about our history right it
seems that the less educated we get
about our history the more we want to
tear down monuments that refer to our
history why is that one I guess
why don't Americans study history
anymore and and and why does it make us
so upset at historical reminders Paul
well I think was we get the talking
points about what the history years let
me just say you'll better see racism and
slavery and oh there's a statue over
there that represents that so we got to
tear it down we don't get the full
historical context and understanding of
why they exist and so that's why we just
have that initial reaction we just get
the base we don't get the full there
there has been a movement in education
to not read primary texts anymore to
only read synopses of primary texts or
secondary or third
and we and we just you know will operate
off of emotion it's not a Sarah let's
tax or the context or any of them and
it's just whatever you feel like crisis
them bad tear everything down
censorship no like you need to
understand the full context you know and
and work from there but just this
immediate gut reaction just go off of
feelings and condemn people as racist or
sexist or biggest that's ever in our
culture you see here but I think this is
important why do you think a healthy
debate needs to be happening in these
towns in the cities where these longings
exist and where I speak that speaks to
the whole idea of them putting in
museums is that are we having an honest
healthy debate where people are saying
what they feel about these things and
art do we have a healthy view of the
Confederacy because sometimes we
necessarily don't I think those that
will naturally resolve itself by having
those kinds of healthy debates rather
than the dictatorial tear them down
right now the left eye level as pounced
on this you know they do this every time
they never let a crisis go to waste
and of course you make a great point if
these towns and these local communities
want to take down their statues that's
totally up to them I suppose but
something tells me those Democratic
socialists of America we show on that
video we're not living in the local
areas the IWW getting bused in there's
obviously a well-funded effort
Soros planks row certainly and that's
another thing too is what they don't
realize is the democratic socialists and
Tifa people who come into these towns
that Shores up the other person's
opinion so so you might have had a town
having a debate whether to take down a
statue but then when these Outsiders
come in and just rip up your public
property well of course you're going to
go no that's my statue you don't have
the authority to do that and so they're
they're actually causing they are
causing the fight and when when they
could have easily just come in say hey
listen why don't you have a debate about
this this is wrong but can it can it be
a rallying point that is the one
counter-argument if they say if we leave
up a statue of Hitler the Nazis are
going to use that as a congregation
point or if we leave up a statue of
Jefferson Davis Richard Spencer is going
to show up there is that any sort of
legitimate argument is there a real
threat of that if there is should we
even care
no I don't think so I think the rallying
point is happening because the left is
just going into these cities and saying
tear them down without allowing any kind
of debate and that's creating a vacuum
that makes the Richard Spencer's in the
neo-nazis go up and rally - have you
noticed that you've never seen poll
blonde Richard Spencer in the same time
I'm just going to leave that out there
you know I and I hope that never happens
fair enough good point good point
I suppose that's right is there any
there's no real threat here this well it
doesn't like it just doesn't solve any
problems of racism by moving a statue or
ripping down a statue what does that
solve there is no debate as Paul is
saying if there's difference you're
deemed a racist if you even have a
counter-argument to this there is no
debate I mean but that's that's the
biggest issue was it doesn't solve
anything other but if a bunch of a bunch
of conservatives rallied around at
Joseph Stalin statue of which there are
several in the United States what are
the we're going to say hey you know
Joseph Stalin tried tried to purge the
Jews out of Russia you know just the
same way hitler did out of germany they
would be defending oh you don't know
what you're talking about
soviet russia was of all about equality
and you know would be all of a sudden
they would want to have a debate so we
have a Stalinist on the panel yeah
Amanda you make a great point too though
there isn't that I think part of the
reason why these views gained currency
online is because there's such an
oppressive culture where if you bring up
any sort of idea I mean I get I did an
entire episode yesterday about how awful
the Nazis are there will be people
online today who call me a racist sexist
and all that sort of it happens to every
single person who's ever voted
Republican and so it allows these views
they're almost subversive they seem cool
when in reality there's stupid ideas
they don't have any serious philosophic
or logical backing and maybe if you
would allow them out to the open they
would die as they as they ought to yeah
that's why that's why this is so
dangerous because there is there is no
dialogue
right now if you you know say anything
remotely on the other side you are a
racist
you're there was um you know this whole
all the Confederate stuff who was it
there was an actor who was calling
everybody at Nazi if they didn't want to
ban free speech for people with certain
ideologies I mean
if you don't want to kill the Jews
you're a Nazi I mean it was just you
know there's just no dialog around this
is not some healthy debate as I masala
date where they decide over a little
different to museum that's not what's
happening what do you think about robert
e lee's argument that it would be
picking at old sores and it'll keep the
scavs alive or reminds us of the evil
that our spin I think I reminded its
actual in reality I mean trying to
decide if you don't want to think about
your hand I agree we load up a little
Gill I mean it never hurt anybody built
your up first yeah I like and you know
maybe we should retreatment all these
identity politics that we have right now
because you know we don't want that that
that evil that racism that we overcame I
mean it's important to remember it we're
not glorifying it it's our history it's
actually what happened to acknowledge or
you can yeah okay here's where I would
maybe disagree with that is because I
think something in the public square is
not necessarily acknowledgment that's
reverence II um and that's where the
debate needs to come into play you know
are we reviewing these or are we just
acknowledging our history that's why a
museum takes place women be keeping on
battlefield I think that's an honest
discussion and I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing that people are
talking about sure but you know if you
if you throw them into those museums you
might as well throw them into drawers
and lock them up right having that's
that it's true you know the old cliche
those who don't remember their history
are doomed to repeat it right you know
so I think it is important that in that
context you know some of these statues
maybe do need to stay up so we so we
don't repeat that history sure well you
know we have so much more to talk about
including bubonic plague but you cannot
see it if you don't go to daily wire
calm right now I want you to stick
around I need you to be here but you can
only do that if you go to daily wire
calm right now it's $10 a month $100 a
year you get the leftist here's tumblr
keeps your leftist here's hot or cold
always salty and delicious and if you
want to watch that this is not a good
example we only have Amanda today but
you know very often it's not just table
and Jacob air here we have a wonderful
panel of deplorable so you got to go to
daily wire calm right now and sign up
president Trump I love him so much he
tweeted out and then deleted a photo
just for the last two days of a Trump
train smashing a person with a CNN logo
for ahead and the caption said fake news
can't stop - Trump Amanda first question
to you how much better is Donald Trump
than all of the other presidents
combined you know how many orders of
magnitude issue one of a kind like you I
mean okay so I'm not a fan of the means
of the WWE stuff but I'm just not a fan
of any number of you actually no no I
like them I don't like when my president
replaces I'm not the biggest fan but it
doesn't matter because the media is so
hysterical and so crazy that anytime
Trump saw something like this their
overreaction keeps calling for the
murder of journalists by the way I don't
think it's a meme I think it's a
documentary yeah so I mean anytime they
react with something present Trump does
that I'm not a fan of I'm like okay I
love it
because they're just so hysterical you
know it's not advocating for some heard
of journalists I want to come down he
does not actually conducting a train
yeah I realize that I mean but Jacob is
it too soon I mean this a poor woman got
mowed down by a Nazi on Saturday is it a
little soon to be posting these images I
think maybe just a little bit too soon
but in all fairness to the president Jim
Acosta was kind of acting like a show
heartbeat I'm sure had a shot to hear
that and it's kind of funny I I think
that name in particular was too soon but
had Trump tweeted out another one I
probably would have been okay with it
cuz in the process ruin CNN for me
completely
yeah I actually love him because he is
Will Ferrell in anchorman I really enjoy
his brother right he does a lot of it I
hope that there's rumors he might get
his own show I hope that's all I will
get one on The Daily wire we
pull wah he deleted the tweet yes was he
right to delete the tweeter shitty of
left it on certainly doesn't help them
if there's one thing about trunk that's
always been beneficial to Trump is that
he's unapologetic unless you think
deleting it doesn't help yeah I think
the bullying it doesn't help one thing
about Trump is that he's unapologetic
and this makes him look apologetic in to
speak to Amanda's point the media always
overreact to this I mean the last time
he did that WWE tweeting and it helped
finding some fifteen-year-old redditor
online heterodox together so leave it up
and probably troll over to the point
that they're kind of do something else
stupid so yeah actually agree with you
yeah I think you should even though I
hate this stuff I think it's just
whatever yeah but but is the mean
correct true or false
fake news can't stop the traffic news
hotels you know it's all a machine
because of people like Jim Acosta I mean
they fueled his base so much they don't
get it and they just they don't
understand they've learned nothing
and they keep fueling him I mean every
time they have an over reaction every
time they you know comma Nazi
sympathizer or whatever it just fuel to
base and when they lie they have to
retract that fuel today so they're fake
there's only help it they are fake news
by the way
they may have been pulling that New York
Times Washington Post CNN have had to
retract major stories fire reporters
we're not talking about just getting a
couple facts wrong they have been
terrible at their job other anonymous
star thing that turned out to be bug why
why is that is it just something about
Trump that works them or have their
standard has fallen for some other
reason I honestly think it's they see
Trump as a traitor right because he used
to be a Democrat one of them he was one
of them and all of a sudden he's not and
they are trying to punish him for it but
they but exactly what you said earlier
there's just shoring up his base that's
that's all there is to it they are they
are oiling that machine and it's going
to keep on going because Trump is so
brash and unapologetic typically they
should really hate that and I think I
feel smack them back that was one of the
things that I really liked about Toronto
smack the media and they just can't
stand it I can't say I'm being called
fake news and all the rest conference
and he talks like a New Yorker which is
I mean
you know that the way New Yorkers
sometimes in people who aren't from that
wonderful place here in New Yorkers
talks why are you so much that means
just a way yeah kind of fun it's just
the way you talk and he does we haven't
seen that in a very long time FDR I
guess was the last New Yorker president
and he did not he did not talk like the
Donald okay we have to move on
speaking of the mainstream media
continuing to harp on President Trump
they're harping on his condemnation of
the Nazis not being emphatic enough and
the Nazis seemed to agree actually so
Richard Spencer called it quote kumbaya
nonsense he said he doesn't take very
seriously
others echoed those sentiments Jacob are
Spencer and the mainstream media correct
no the Spencer is just doing this to get
attention we didn't even know who
Spencer was until the media started
recording on him of course he would have
no platform right now but because the
mainstream media want to somehow tie
this guy to Trump this this horrible
racist they want to tie him to Trump
they're just going to report every
single little thing he says it's been
especially if he says Trump by name but
he does I mean these guys I'm all for
admitting that the Nazis are they have
leftist premises I'm all for saying that
I think these are fundamentally
left-wing movements but there are also a
little bit right-wing movements to write
these guys did vote for President Trump
so there is some Association there yeah
I think he got so the media are going to
overreact they're going to say things
that aren't true no matter what they're
going to go in term to matter what but I
think Trump got himself in trouble he
should have named right up a day I
should have named both groups antifa and
and neo-nazis because that's I mean you
know that's exactly wonderful very
violent one exam I mean obviously the
Nazi lab is car but all of those little
attacks right you saw the canister with
a homemade flamethrower and the rocks
and all that that seem to all be an Tifa
or largely antifa right so when this was
coming out I maybe should have condemned
both sides specifically called out the
man with what some white supremacist I
you murdered
expressing denounce at all because he
didn't and it was kind of it almost
sounded like he was going off-script in
his reading that you know 9525 trying to
not take I think Trump is annoyed that
they're being tied to him because he
hasn't he has been known because they
would do it anyway I mean they do it to
every Republican they say when did you
stop beating your wife yeah and I think
it's that sort of moment so I don't
think is s setting this various of Trump
I might be naive to not name no specific
I think you just annoyed that they're
being tight in any way so I'm saying
everyone everyone there doesn't want to
name them by name because then it's tied
to him except what the media is trying
to do but because of that when Trump
comes out a second time and then names
them you have these white supremacist
who are saying I didn't really mean it I
took him they made him do it yeah and
that's the problem that Trump sets into
by doing created it for himself
yeah right well did he is he just
playing footsie with fascists here or is
he damned if he does and damned if he
doesn't I think he's damned if he does
damn Vinny doesn't so you don't you
don't think he's winking at these guys
at all I know keep their hair laying my
honest opinion as it is I think it's a
strong King Trump I think he just wanted
to say what he wanted to say and that is
say on many sides and he's not
necessarily thinking clearly that people
are going to want him to tailor his
rhetoric towards specifically condemning
white supremacists so he just comes out
he says it and then huge blowback and
everybody's like saying yeah you got a
condemned specifically and he's like
well I said what I wanted to say and so
okay now he goes out and says it and
looks like he's just you know caving to
press demanded see ads that's my opinion
I was just going to add you know I think
we also have to be careful on the rights
criticism of Trump on this because when
Obama would come out and say anything
that had to do you know with the Dallas
any time a police officer shot in on our
an unarmed suspect Obama would go out
immediately reactionary and then we on
the right would always go oh wait wait
let's let's measure let's let's get all
the facts and then I think Trump did
that as well he's like why he gave a
station you know effective saturation
yeah so and then when he got all the
facts he came out and condemned them I I
do think in this case since we know it
wasn't even y'know neo-nazis he should
have done it but I also think some of
the criticism is being a little harsh on
him well
yeah they're also just totally media and
everyone in America it feels like it's
just totally ignoring you know when
President Obama would never name like
I've met or never named he was thriller
writer my my child would look like
Trayvon Martin yeah exactly and
first-timers we forgot all this I mean
oh I know blacklivesmatter sympathizer
murder fight cop in Dallas
he didn't condemn black eye matter
around it is not racism you know memory
holding nobody remembers that and other
great at their funeral right but
President Trump I mean President Obama
was wrong to do that and I also think
President Trump should have named both
Antipa and Vinny adapted and he should
name President Obama I look yeah here's
a blame Bush I want a little bit more
blame yeah well now those answers were
not hysterical enough so we need to
Ratchet it up a little bit and talk
about bubonic plague in other signs of
the Apocalypse the black death appears
to have made a return to the United
States fleas carrying bubonic plague
which killed 50 million people in the
14th century and took out between 25 and
60 percent of the European population
have infected three victims in Arizona
Paul bois is our Lord's return to judge
the living and the dead eminent well as
our Lord said Michael it is not up to us
to know season so idea--but even you so
I'd be a bit more concern of Antipa
mortgaging your show one day and then
the black day and my rapture issue
actually
Amanda we always talk about our news
cycle as if it is the end of the world
you know every election is the most
important election of my lifetime and
everything this is the end the
conservative movements over the right
wing as though the country's over is it
is there anything right now is our time
especially dire or is this just typical
hysteria I think I think it's a typical
hysteria I kind of follow to this to a
little bit I thought we're all all die
of Ebola and because I don't want of
honor I really like terrify over yeah I
didn't calm me down so we're going to be
fine but yeah it's to get hysterical
stuff I mean if you look at you know
everything in context then this kind of
stuff happened
we'll be alright but our culture is
rotting though I won't say that that is
the plague yeah that is all a hundred
years Jacob
we have would you make a fair point that
the culture might be decaying but we are
living through basically the greatest
time of peace and prosperity in the
history of the world and yet rates of
anxiety around the rise depression are
on the rise why are people not happy I
think it's the media the mainstream
media always turns out anything if it
bleeds it leads right so they're always
churning out everything that could
possibly go wrong I mean if you remember
when the Malaysian airline plane
vanished how could I forget
yes CNN harped on that for six freaking
months okay it's not we don't know what
happened to it it's either send someone
to Malaysia investigate or shut up you
know it doesn't they run these stories
over and over again and it's basically
it's it's basically pornography for the
for people who have anxiety so there I'm
all for blaming the news I blame that it
may not be all day long as you've got to
this point of the culture decaying yeah
I think that might be part of it there
is a we have all the money in the world
now we're we are richer than anyone has
ever been is there some sense that
that's not quite gratifying we've turned
away from yeah look at any feminist over
40 along with yeah I'm serious though I
mean that is not punch it is not
happiness like oh yeah you have a career
and nobody and I'm alone that's not
that's not happiness oh sure yeah that
is we generally want to be in ruins
everything
yeah but uh dr. Peter craved of Boston
College are really kind of said it best
all of our technological advances is all
great how but we've made a greater how
and for a lesser why we don't
necessarily know why why were we have
all these signals why we have our houses
and which it's always about what we're
doing yeah what we're doing it's always
about proclaiming the glory of God and
that is a that collapsed in the 1960s
that is a pretty dire way to end but we
have to also thank you the panel of
deplorable
Paul Blom and oppressed
Jockamo Jacob arey now it is time for
the final thought inside every social
justice warrior is a tyrant yearning to
spring out the left famously never lets
a crisis go to waste and our American
Taliban has seized on the crimes of a
handful of idiots and criminals in
Charlottesville to finally topple our
Biloxi Buddhas that impulse is
revisionist anti historic and unamerican
the truth above all things toppling
statues achieves nothing other than
obscuring our history it's an attack on
our ability to understand our country
and ourselves and robert e lee is only
the beginning the left's rapacious
appetite to whitewash our history will
grow only more ravenous who's to say
where it will turn its fangs next who's
to say I don't know
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show thanks for being here come
back tomorrow we'll do it again
[Music]